First, we subtract 12 from both sides to get x squared plus 6x equals negative
12. The b value is positive 6, so we need to add b over 2 squared, or 9, to
both sides of our equation. This allows us to rewrite the left side as a
perfect square. X plus 3 squared. The right side just simplifies to negative 3.
Next we take the square root of both sides of the equation to get x plus 3
equals plus or minus the square root of negative 3. This square root simplifies
to plus or minus i root 3. It's an imaginary root here, since this radicand is
negative. Finally, we subtract 3 from both sides to get x is equal to negative
3 plus or minus i times root 3. Our final answers. Excellent work if you found
these two imaginary solutions.